- Time to...
Buzz is legit.
That's the best
buzz of the year.
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
- [DRock] You had a good break?
- Yeah. Really, really good.
Really good.
No Wine Library,
VaynerMedia, you know?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- All the stress has been
pent up all just my brand stuff,
you know?
Gonna be busy and
fun it'll be perfect.
- [DRock] Yeah.
(light music)
From when you have
taken over with Gary,
what has been your main focus?
- We've actually gone through
a bunch of
different focuses throughout.
The main thing number one was
helping him feel really good.
That was from day one to now the
most important thing was make
sure he feels really good.
No pain, so we've improved his
soft tissue probably all over
especially in his hips and
his legs and then now also in
addition to that we want to
stack on some muscle for the
next couple months before we
start doing a little
bit of the summer cut.
- Summer cut means I'm
gonna lose 15 pounds but all the
muscle's gonna be there,
DRock and that
means shirtless keynotes.
(group laughter)
(light music)
- That was good.
- We're working up to a top set
of six so how far you can go.
- With the camera on,
when the lights come on, shy.
You should see how
shy I am in real life.
(group laughter)
Just kidding.
- [DRock] How many
days a week do you work out?
- [Jordan] Seven days a week.
- [DRock] But are
they all weight lifting?
- [Jordan] No, no, no.
So about four days a week are
heavy strength work and then
three days a week are,
I'll do mobility,
if he can play ball,
we'll play ball.
We haven't done that in a while.
Recovery stuff, a
lot of soft tissue stuff.
- [Gary] What probably gives
me the audacity to give the
business advice that I give is
the fact that I've
figured out this this world.
This did not come natural to me.
There's fat Gary keynotes.
Cut it in right now, Tyler.
And you have to do it.
It's like exercise, right?
This book and what
I just told you is right.
Right?
But so is the way to get a
six-pack in your stomach, right?
There is a right way to get
a six-pack for your stomach.
There's exercises
right and there's a diet.
I know what they are.
I'm not doing it.
(audience laughter)
Like I used to even
wonder if my business advice
was real, was it
was really hardwired?
Was I just completely talented
and others would try but they'd
have no chance but
just making that
switch of going all-in.
Not doing tactics, yes,
DRock has he been working out.
- Yeah.
- I said no
because you're not unless
you completely
go black-and-white.
That's it.
Everybody in our
circles, you know?
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- Friends and
family, they're not.
They might be that moment
but just ask them
another week later.
Everybody's making New
Years resolutions right now but
can't wait, I can't
wait, mark the date,
DRock as soon as
I'm done with this rant,
put on your
calendar February 19th.
I'm gonna make a
video I'm gonna be like,
"It's your
February 19th resolution,
"how's your
New Year's one going?"
I know how it's going.
Not well.
So you gotta make
the binary switch.
If you make that binary
switch you'll work a lot.
I'm not gonna
have excuses any more.
I'm gonna be very patient.
I'm gonna learn how
to build a business,
then things can happen.
Just like I made
the switch here.
Forever, seven
days a week for life.
That was all just to
buy an extra minute's rest.
(group laughter)
- But at top, I want
you to pause at the top.
Pause at the top, pause.
I was at the gym and I was just
looking at what
everyone was doing.
I was just like no one's
doing that kind of weight.
Normal gym goers,
they just don't do that.
- [Gary] What do they do?
- 30, 35s, maybe 40s.
- [Gary] They
just in maintain mode?
- They're people who go to
the gym everyday and do the same
things over and over again.
Maybe texting between sets
they're pretty
consistent people.
It's like...
- Just a lot of
make up work to do.
When you don't do
anything, you're 38,
you got to make it up.
That's another good segue.
It is.
It's like if you're 41 you're
gonna have to be more extreme
than if you're 17.
It's pattern, it's
learning from patterns,
it's getting used to routine.
If you've been doing
something for 40 years,
unsuccessfully, you've got
to completely do it differently.
So I'm pushing it harder because
I deserve to pay the price.
Those people doing 30s,
they've been doing it every day
for 15 years, they can be okay.
- [Jordan] Right.
- I got to go to 50s
because I got
more time to make up.
- [Jordan] One more.
Done.
- This is how you
work out, right DRock?
- [DRock] Yep.
- When you work out.
- [DRock] Identical.
- It's a lot.
- [Jordan] What?
We're doing a lot?
Yeah.
- Getting all those
calories worth, huh?
- Yep.
And the stronger you
get the more essentially
we're going to be doing.
- [DRock] The stronger you
get the more you're going to be
actually doing.
- Well, that's right.
The reason I can
work 17 hours a day now,
'cause I put in
the work 8 hours a day,
10 hours a day, 12 hours a day.
You can't go from zero,
sitting around being lazy to
oh I saw a GaryVee
quote on Instagram,
now I'm gonna
work 18 hours a day.
- [Jordan] Right.
- You can't.
- [Jordan] You can't.
- It's too much of a shock.
- [Jordan] You got to
adapt to each little bit.
- Can't do it two days a week.
You got to find a rhythm.
Everybody's different.
You can.
I've done things in working
out that you shouldn't have been
able to right away.
- [Jordan] Right.
Yeah, for sure.
- Got to know yourself.
Self-awareness.
Good workout.
Funny day today.
Kind of half on, half off.
- [Jordan] Yeah.
- Everyone's kind of off and
I'll go to Vayner a little bit,
VaynerSports meeting, Vayner
Capital with Phil then go back
and milk a little more time
with the fam before
we go into serious
pain tomorrow.
Pain is slang term
for awesome execution.
(group laughter)
Shit, thank you.
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Jordan] Good stuff, man.
- [Gary] Thank you.
See you guys in a little bit.
- [DRock] Yep.
- Time to...
Buzz is legit.
That's the best
buzz of the year.
There we go.
So, time to get my haircut.
Got the workout in.
Fresh cut for the year.
Really excited.
Super excited
about implementing,
hey be up in a sec.
Super excited about
everybody flipping stuff.
We got to talk about that
before the end of the day.
Cool.
- [DRock] How are you?
- [Gary] Look at
all this shit, DRock.
Just want to sell it.
Look at this shit.
Just sell it.
Sell shit.
Need a hammer?
Here it is.
DRock, you know how much
this hammer would go for?
- [DRock] $20?
- Yeah, $7.99.
Better than zero especially
when you don't have it.
You know?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- How much will a DRock go for?
I got some good stuff.
This thing is
so fucking awesome.
- [DRock] You
have two hammers. $14.
- Where's the other hammer?
- [DRock] Right there.
- [Gary] Fuck, two hammers.
$14, this one
might go for nine. $16.
Anyway, alright guys, gonna
get ready for this meeting.
Love you and just remember,
everybody's got a price.
- [DRock] Great rant.
I have this really
interesting 2017 challenge.
It is my belief that everybody
has a ton of tchotchkes,
ton of clothes,
ton of electronics.
I'm trying to find my iPhone but
different generation iPhones.
I'm about to send a tweet with
give me an update on
your eBay flip stories.
Give it context, I know tweets
only have 140 characters but
maybe a picture of your eBay
account or of the sold item.
DRock is about to
make a 3 to 4 minute,
you know, eBay
testimonial kind of blueprint.
Like what am
I actually talking about.
I'm creating a
$21,700 challenge.
I believe that everybody if
they convert 210 hours
into hustling and flipping stuff
will be able to by the end of
year amass $21,000 in
profit for their account.
I'm about to send a tweet,
go to Twitter and reply to it.
Love you, see ya.
(hammer banging on table)
- [Phil] (laughs)
That's intimidating.
Logistics...
(light music)
- I want to go
self-deprecating,--
- [Phil] Mhmmm.
- hard on the
thing that they perceive,
'cause you're not gonna
convince them else wise.
- [Phil] Exactly.
- You've gotten
to see it from me.
I might even take you guys to a
VaynerMedia meeting where you
see me play self-deprecation
'cause you'll understand my
strategy around it.
Because in these
meetings it's the marketing,
super confident football self.
You might be thinking
I'm asking you to do that.
I just don't think you
fight the decision maker.
I never fight
the decision maker.
So when they say to me,
you guys go do television.
I'm like we don't do television.
- [Phil] Mhmmm.
- 100%. I got to go.
You need anything else?
(light music)
Alright, gonna go back
and sneak some family time
in before we go really, really
full time today but grind out
some quality stuff.
Good meeting on Vayner Capital.
Lot of people forget about, lot
of people forget that GaryVee
thing is my side hustle.
Venture capital,
sports agency, media agency,
wine shop.
I'm plenty busy
but this felt good.
It's good to get
back in the grind.
DRock, great to see you.
Tyler, good to see you.
- [Tyler] How's it going?
- And this eBay
video should be good.
And appreciate all
the love on Instagram.
Been really into, it's
really hard core right now.
Lot of engagement.
Really gotten the
community engagement on the
DMs and comments down.
So that's been cool.
See you tomorrow.
Well, something just
popped up for Vayner Sports.
It's a busy time for us
so now I'm headed back out.
I have to put the kids to
bed and hustling some more.
You know, you either put
in the work or you don't.
(light music)